all right let's uh answer some audience
questions Friday the last thing we like
to do before the bonus show of course is
take three questions from the audience
and answer them in a little more detail
than we usually get into during the
voicemail segment so first question is
from i believe the pronunciation is
latef have you ever thought about
running for office in the future would
you ever think about trying to run for
office this has come up not doing
audience questions but sort of just in
different segments it has crossed my
mind and we recently spoke about on a
bonus show earlier in the week actually
the idea of trying to change the system
from outside versus from inside and many
people think the most effective way to
change it is from the inside others who
feel that actually if the system gets
you in power you're way less likely to
want to change it once you get into it
not that long ago I was actually
approached about running for a state
level position which had become
available and i was told listen you know
with with the platform you have in media
and the number of votes that would be
required to win you would probably be a
shoo-in and I I evaluated it and I would
only have done it you know all these
positions are sort of part time in
Massachusetts where the legislative
session doesn't go year-round or seven
days a week I could have probably done
the job while continuing to do the show
but I would not really have been able to
campaign in the way that I that I
probably should have to really do it in
a serious manner as i like to say so i
opted against it but conceptually i'm
not against at some point looking into
public office although of course i could
never be President because I was not
born in the United States uh but I sort
of go back and forth over time about
whether I could really have any impact
you know well don't forget Obama wasn't
born in the United States either and he
still became president amazing app but
he planned it for 46 years leading up to
being elected I would only just start
planning it now you know he also has
some how high the best forgers in the
world yeah for his documents not good
enough for Alex Jones to not figure out
that it's a fake birth certificate that
nobody falls Alex Jones nobody uh I
don't think I could do it uh I just
knowing what I know about the system and
the people in it yeah I don't think I
could handle it I would probably end up
murdering someone and will
it just wouldn't be good for my health
it's much easier to get away with murder
if you are a high-level elected official
than if you're just some rat random dude
that is true uh but still it just seems
way too stressful uh my blood pressure
would it would probably go through the
roof um it just seems as someone who as
may be the only person who would want to
change the system once you become once
you reach office yeah imagine it just
seems way too stressful and um and it
III wanna help but I don't think that it
would be it would be good for me jason
has it ever crossed your mind wasn't say
but think about the stressing you can do
and you could finally managed live in
winter New England again now not worth
it now too rich if you allow climate
change to continue unfettered eventually
it'll be warm enough to suit you in New
England uh so I should be a Republican
that's what you're saying and just deny
all of that uh well sometime to say it's
too late anyway which would you uh run
for office Jason and environmental
issues are a big thing for you I think
I'm the same boat as Lewis here I don't
think it's worth the the stress the
lifestyle you know granted I could get
away with murder and driving off a
bridge with a girl in the car and so
across the island sound but probably not
worth it listen if that had happened to
you you also would have called your
lawyer first and the police only the
next day like uh certainly like the late
great Ted Kennedy did that day I am
actually able to separate Ted Kennedy as
a lawmaker from the incredibly sketchy
in bizarre circumstances of the
Chappaquiddick incident um I don't know
if I can separate them but he certainly
did have a a as far as politicians go he
was one of the one of the good ones
whatever that means yeah alright so yeah
I'd consider it at some point seems like
Louis wouldn't